how do you spot a hero
a hero stands up for others they prevent
destruction caused by powerful
technologies forces of nature or human
folly they protect life
we might now picture a fictional
character but heroes like this do exist
in the real world
without the capes and masks they're just
not as easy to recognize
instead they are ordinary people who
find themselves in extraordinary
situations at a crossroads with
significance far beyond themselves and
at that crucial point in the face of
peril resistance and personal risk they
decide to act for the good of all life
on earth
a hero holds the torch to see the way
forward towards a better future
can we see ourselves in this position
heroes from the past have much to teach
us let's meet some of them now
in october 1962 at the peak of the cuban
missile crisis vasili arquipov found
himself stationed on a soviet submarine
equipped with a nuclear torpedo that had
just been discovered by the us navy near
cuba
dying batteries had created overheated
conditions
sailors were fainting from lack of
oxygen in communication with moscow had
been cut off for over a week
when the americans dropped depth charges
to signal the soviet submarine to
surface both the captain and political
officer concluded that world war iii had
started
exhausted nervous and without radio
signal to clarify the situation the two
decided to launch a nuclear torpedo at
the us fleet despite the extremely tense
situation vasily arkhipov kept a cool
head
sensing that they were not under attack
he alone vetoed the launch thus his
torch led us away from a devastating
nuclear war between the ussr and the
united states
unfortunately the cold war tension
continued and by 1983 global nuclear
arsenals had more than doubled
enter our second hero stanislav pietrov
on a late september night he was on duty
observing the soviet early warning
network when the system alerted him of
five incoming american nuclear missiles
i just sat there for a few seconds
staring at the screen with the word
launch displayed in bold red letters but
i had a funny feeling in my gut he
suspected the missile detections were
false
with the world's destiny at his
fingertips he went with his gut rather
than blindly trusting the computer
and he was right
for the second time in a quarter century
the extraordinary resolve of a
responsible human led us away from the
unimaginable destruction of nuclear war
we've since learned that arkhipov and
pietrov saved us from even more harm
than they could have realized at the
time
now we know that an all-out nuclear
conflict can create a nuclear winter
extreme enough to cause global
starvation
the last century saw the emergence of
another technology with the potential to
wipe out billions of lives
bioweapons
in the 1960s matthew mazelson was
consulting for the us army when he was
shown vast quantities of anthrax being
manufactured for biological warfare
here meselson saw a major crossroads
humanity would either turn away from
this development or embark on an
unstoppable arms race in weapons of mass
destruction that were much cheaper than
nukes and much easier to make enabling
everyone from rogue states to terrorist
groups to get hold of them
going down this path would not only
tarnish biotech forever it could also
profoundly alter our humanity by
attacking our very dna
meselson decided to reject the fear and
panic taking humanity down that road
i felt a strong desire to get this thing
stopped
armed with all the facts he needed to
formulate a solid argument he managed to
convince henry kissinger president nixon
and most of the biology community to
embark on an alternative path
thanks to his conviction and
persuasiveness world leaders signed the
biological weapons convention in 1972
banning both their development and use
meanwhile another biological killer had
been ravaging the globe for centuries
smallpox was one of the worst diseases
ever to afflict our species
until two heroes confronted it
in 1958 soviet virologist viktor zhanov
with great persistence managed to
convince the world health assembly to
launch the smallpox eradication program
on which the usa and the soviet union
collaborated despite the cold war to
make this global effort a success
epidemiologist william fagey developed
innovative surveillance and containment
techniques enabling total eradication
while vaccinating only a small fraction
of the population
in 1980 smallpox was declared fully
eradicated which according to unicef has
saved over 200 million and counting
this success shows that making the world
a better place can involve many
persistent collaborators over many years
and collaboration was also vital in
saving the earth's ozone layer
ozone destruction and the resulting
damage to our crops skin and dna is
another horrific scenario we don't have
to live out thanks to the contributions
of three more heroes
joseph farman's remarkable antarctic
measurements led his team to discover an
alarmingly large and expanding hole in
the earth's protective ozone layer
susan solomon was the sherlock holmes of
atmospheric science cracking the long
unsolved puzzle of how cfcs chemicals
then widely used including infringes
spray cans and inhalers were destroying
ozone so fast over antarctica i was a
young scientist i was 29 at the time and
i decided that i was going to try to
take my photochemical model and make it
stand on its head and when all those
measurements were in
people got pretty convinced with the
world alerted and willing to act stephen
anderson of the environmental protection
agency stepped up and tirelessly guided
multiple industry sectors away from
using cfcs
all three contributed to the signing of
the montreal protocol in 1987 to date
the most successful international
environmental treaty ever
because of these heroes the ozone hole
is now closing
together these stories show how life on
earth can be defended and supported
through science global consensus
innovation and hard work
this takes individual heroes committed
to doing the right thing
to speaking up researching writing
persisting not for themselves not for
money power or glory but for all of us
and for everyone still to come
each person in these stories received
the future of life award recognizing
those who made the world a much better
place than it might otherwise have been
and now they pass the torches onwards a
new generation of heroes awaits let's
all light our torches and the path
towards a better future will be even
brighter
you